Figuring out weather your crush likes you is one of the hardest things to figure out
Because when it comes to attraction, things are usually kept pretty subtle
You have to look pretty close, if you want to see the signs that someone likes you
Here's what to keep an eye out for
1. They respond to the sound of your voice
The sound of your voice can seriously attract other people
Many studies have found that women are attracted to deeper voices in men
Whereas men like higher voices in women
Fast talkers are seen as seen as more educated
And if you can change up your inflection,
you are seen as more interesting
Your crush might be in love with the sound of your voice,
so keep an eye out to see if they are responding to your voice with a smile or a laugh
If this is the case, there might be a spark of attraction
2. They play hard to get
The rumours are true, playing hard to get is a big sign of attraction
When we're with someone who's playing hard to get, we usually work that much harder to get their attention
and that makes the seduction process much more intense
This all comes down to one thing,
availability
Appearing to be less available can make people want you even more
3. Uncrossed legs
Body language also reveals alot about availability
For example, when someone uncrosses their legs and arms,
they are basically saying; I'm available
This is a basic body language in both men and women
So this rule also applies to same sex couples
There are plenty of other signs of open body language
such as unturned palms, maintaining eye contact, and many more
4. They talk about being single
Let's stick on the topic of availability
because its such a huge factor in attraction
When someone suddenly drops a hint of being single,
its a great sign
So if someone suddenly mentions that they're single, maybe its the right time to make a move
Because who knows, they might be sending out signals of availability, as a sign of attraction
5. Leaning in
A 2014 study, identified 5 seperate flirting styles
and leaning in was a huge sign of attraction that was mentioned
They specified that leaning in on an angle from the hip is a big sign of flirting
So if your crush is leaning into you after you make them laugh,
it could be a major sign of attraction
so keep an eye out for that
6. Revealing personal info
As a general rule, the more personal info a person reveals,
the more interested they are in you
That's what a recent study found , when they studies flirting techniques
this can still be done in a subtle way
for example, someone might reveal that they are dealing with a hardbreaking loss or a major setback
but in a slightly casual way
7. Teasing
In that same study, the researchers also studied the signs of flirting that might arise during a conversation
and teasing was a big part of that
They specified that teasing consisted of making fun of another person in a light-hearted way
We're guessing that alot of our viewers have probably experienced teasing in their own flirting experiences
but remember: Keep teasing light-hearted and fun
Never make fun of someone for things they are insecure about
No matter how much you're crushing on them
8. Eye pupils and dilation are linked with arousal
We all know that eyes are windows to the soul
but if you stare deep enough into your crush's eyes
you might just get a clue as to weather they are into you
Studies have shown, that when people become aroused,
their pupils actually DILATE
This is actually a pretty good sign of sexual orientation as well
Your eyes will dilate when you look at the gender you are most attracted to
9. Playing with nearby objects
When some people get nervous, they fidget
They might play with their hair, their bracelets, or their nails
But according to a recent study,
those same behaviors might be linked with attraction
researchers found, that people that are flirting often found themselves playing
with buttons on their shirts, zippers, strings and many other nearby objects
10. Mirroring
Another big sign of attraction, is mirroring
if you look closely, you might find that your crush seems to be copying your movements
& behaviors in a subtle way
it might be tilting their head to the side in the same way as you
or adopting a similar posture
Mirroring has been studied quite intensively in psychological research
Which of these signs do you find interesting and believable?
Let us know your own experiences in the comments below! :)
Also, please check out our friends
go check it out guys, understanding will help us bond better! Its very interesting
have a great day ahead!!
Ig: @mirusha__